whatever happened to you  you have gifts now everything breaks  victory i can't wait to see what you  compete  in the world of ones and zeroes you are  the  these boxes will get inside you and find  your weaknesses and your fears  take your place among the brave ones  i'm not broken and i'm not  alone  you can turn your back on the world  forever  above or below thousands of years since  our people spoke the first  born of beloved queen and blood i need  warriors be scared  the time has come take up your mother's  private  this is a bad idea  fighting the devil in his army you know  the whole world is mourning grieving  over a symbol  let's hope you're not too late it's like  they were afraid of him fly  son it's time i made a promise on his  grace without him  do this together  [Music]  they wanted me back for a reason  i need to find out why  you